after 10 days of talks in Pretoria
Ethiopia's federal government and the
Tigre people's Liberation Front reached
an agreement to end the fighting the
talks are mediated by former Nigerian
president olusegun obasanjo and former
Kenyan president Uhuru Kenyatta today
is the beginning of a new town for
Ethiopia
for the owner of Africa
and indeed
for Africa as a whole
let me explain to some God for this
Newton
we are seeing in practice and
actualization
what we have tried to achieve for
ourselves over the years
and that is
African solution
for African problems
the two-year conflicts killed thousands
of people and forced many more from
their homes
Tigre in Ethiopia's North has been under
a blockade for 17 months with no banking
telephone and internet services or media
access
the degree and delegation says it's made
painful concessions and that trust must
now be rebolt our people have
not only through bullets but also
for lack of
food and Medicine
our children do not go to schools our
hospitals
are not functional
because of the war
humanitarian Aid is now expected to
resume the tplf dominated Ethiopia's
politics for nearly 30 years until prime
minister ABI Ahmad came to power in
2018.
as both sides fought for territory human
rights campaigners have warned of
potential abuses by both sides in the
conflict
[Music]
we must be true to the letter in the
spirit of this argument
the people of Ethiopia expected more
than the text of this argument
they demand peace and harmony
they desire development
international calls for an end to the
war have been mounting in recent weeks
while the federal government has been
assisted by troops from neighboring
Eritrea that country was not involved in
the talks this is not the first time
there's been an agreement to end the
fighting a previous ceasefire fell apart
in August this year this time though
there appears to be a greater commitment
and optimism that this agreement will
hold famide Al Jazeera Pretoria